Punkte Dietmar Bartsch der jetzt am Pult
es war auch schon mal da ist nur ein
bisschen länger her
drei Viertel der BundesbürgerInnen und
Bundesbürger sind laut Deutschlandtrend
unzufrieden mit ihrer Regierung ist auch
kein Wunder selten haben so viele
Menschen in so kurzer Zeit so viel ihres
bescheidenen Wohlstands verloren wie
unter ihnen sie wollten
fortschrittskoalition sein nun hatten
sie ein Jahr lang Zeit in ihrem ersten
ampelhaushalt genau das abzubilden und
ich kann feststellen oder muss
feststellen es ist kaum eine Spur von
mehr Fortschritt und eins hat die
heutige Debatte deutlich gezeigt nur
ihre selbst Zufriedenheit kann die
Unzufriedenheit im Land noch toppen
meine Damen und Herren
will ihre mangelnde Fähigkeit die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger vor der
Preisexplosion zumindest etwas zu
schützen am Beispiel der Gaspreise
deutlich machen erst wollten sie gar
keine gaspreisbremse sondern eine
gasumlage also noch höhere Preise dann
eine eine Bremse nach dem Winter also
März jetzt im Januar was für ein Chaos
das versteht kein Abgeordnete mehr
geschweige denn die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und wie soll dann ein Betrieb mit
dieser Herangehensweise seine Zukunft
planen lieber Herr Bundeskanzler sie
leiten kein Kabinett das solide arbeitet
sondern da sind einige diletten am Start
oder richtiger gesagt dilettantinnen und
diletten am Start heute
heute heute verzweifeln viele Menschen
an ihren Rechnungen heute wandern Firmen
ab oder melden Insolvenz an spätestens
zu Beginn der Heizperiode hätten sie
einen gaspreisdeckel ein ölpreisdeckel
geben müssen wir haben das hier im
Haushalt Monaten gefordert die
dezemberhilfe soll die gastkunden jetzt
irgendwann mit der nächsten
Jahresabrechnung erreichen jetzt und
nicht irgendwann brauchen die Menschen
Unterstützung für die Sicken
auch noch die strompreisspende Bremse
Monate später zu kommen meine Güte ihre
Politik hat mehr Verspätung als die
Deutsche Bahn meine Damen und Herren
aber sie sind nicht nur die zu
spätkoalition sondern sie sind auch die
zu wenig Koalition ein Deckel für 12 von
12 Cent für Gas mein damit ist der
Gaspreis noch immer doppelt so hoch wie
vor dem furchtbaren Krieg Putins das ist
die Wahrheit oder 40 Cent für Strom das
sind auch 12 Cent mehr pro
Kilowattstunde das sind alles Deckelchen
beides ist viel zu hoch und vor allen
Dingen meine Damen und Herren sind ihre
Bremsen auch noch zutiefst sozial
ungerecht und ich will ihnen das auch
erklären der willenbesitzer der
profitiert am meisten je höher der
Verbrauch 2022 war desto höher ist die
Entlastung 20 23 das ist doch ungerecht
sie entlasten gut Verdiener deutlich
mehr als Geringverdiener und die Mitte
der schon gespart hat der guckt den dumm
aus der Wäsche meine Damen und Herren
warum gibt es denn kein festes
bürgerkontingent für Strom und Gas pro
Person pro Haus pro Familie korrigieren
Sie diese Ungerechtigkeit meine Damen
und Herren viele Bürger lassen nicht
allein nein sie lassen sie allein und im
übrigen auch hier zeigt Österreich wie
man es richtig macht in Österreich
werden die Strompreise bei 10 Cent
gedeckelt wir haben weiterhin die
höchsten Strompreise in Europa und das
ist verheerend für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und für die Betriebe ihre Politik
macht aus der Industrienation eine
kerzenrepublik und das ist inakzeptabel
meine Damen und Herren
und dazu gilt bei ihnen noch das Prinzip
jeder Versorger kann abkassieren wie er
will ob die Preise nun 20 und 30 und 40
Cent steigen ob sie verdoppelt werden
oder verdreifer alles ist möglich und im
Übrigen findet leider auch alles aktuell
statt und damit muss Schluss sein Herr
harberg Versorger sollten sich ihre
Tarife genehmigen lassen müssen wir
brauchen staatliche Preiskontrollen in
Deutschland beenden Sie den Wilden
Westen bei denen auf dem Energiemarkt
der die Menschen ruiniert meine Damen
und Herren
oder die Spritpreise da wollten sie das
Bundeskartellamt scharf stellen sie
haben gesagt mit Klauen und Zähnen
herabag und was ist die Wahrheit ein
Miezekätzchen ist die Wahrheit das ist
korrekt die
Ölmultis die verdienen sich dumm und
dämlich 38 Milliarden Euro übergewinne
in diesem Jahr wann holen Sie das Geld
zurück das den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
aus der Tasche gezogen worden ist
reales ist doch so je mehr stellen und
total an der Preis Schraube den desto
mehr verdient auch der Finanzminister
über die Mehrwertsteuer das gleiche gilt
im übrigen auch in der Supermarktkasse
teure Lebensmittel teurere Energien
desto höher sind die Steuereinnahmen die
Wahrheit ist 50 Milliarden Euro mehr in
diesem Jahr und da frage ich Sie was ist
denn eigentlich mit der übergewinnsteuer
also die sie ja zufallsgewinnsteuer
nennen also als Marktwirtschaftler
überzeugt mich das nicht aber sei doch
wann schöpfen sie die Zufalls Gewinne
bei den Profiteuren der Krise denn mal
ab auch hier gilt sie kommen zu spät und
jetzt wollen sie die zufallsgewinne
nicht mehr rückwirkend ab März 2022
sondern erst ab November 2022 abschöpfen
na Donnerwetter Energiekonzern müsste
man sein das wäre wunderbar meine Damen
und Herren wir befinden uns real,-
[Applaus]
Koalition warum haben Sie denn beim
Bürgergeld und beim Wohngeld das nicht
schon im Sommer auf den Weg gebracht
erst im November fünf vor zwölf das hat
doch der Union dass die Möglichkeit
gegeben und eins muss ich jetzt wirklich
mal sagen Herr Scholz sie sagen hier
kein Kind in Armut sie haben die
Grundsicherung verschoben nach einem
Jahr Olaf Scholz ist die Armutsrate bei
Kindern bei über 20 Prozent das ein
Höchstwert da können sie ihr doch nicht
sagen wir lassen kein Kind zurück und
genauso ähnlich ist es auch bei den
Bürgergeld ja der Entwurf da habe ich
hier auch im Plenum einiges gelobt das
ist eine Verbesserung aber was sie jetzt
als Kompromiss haben das ist ausgetragen
auf dem Rücken der Betroffenen und
deswegen kritisieren wir das auch in
Deutlichkeit diesen Kompromiss meine
Damen und Herren
und jetzt so eine Bemerkung für
Schuldenbremse also der Finanzminister
hat jetzt seine Schuldenbremse bekommen
die Schuldenbremse ist ja für die FDP
wie der Schnuller für das Baby wenn das
man ihn wegnimmt dann ist das Geschrei
riesig groß aber meine Damen und Herren
die Neuverschuldung beträgt trotzdem
45,6 Milliarden Euro und Herr
Finanzminister diese Verschuldung ist
wirklich eine blanke Lügengeschichte und
das wissen sie in jedem Betrieb wäre das
Bilanzfälschung meine Damen und Herren
ein solches Vorgehen hat mit
haushaltsklarheit und haushaltswahrheit
aber auch wirklich gar nicht zu tun sie
haben Schattenhaushalte in Größenordnung
errichtet um die Schuldenbremse
einhalten zu können sonderschulden für
das Sondervermögen ich meine
Sondervermögen bei 100 Milliarden das
ist kreditfinanziert am Haushalt
letztlich vorbei für die Aufrüstung der
Bundeswehr das sind Schulden und nichts
anderes und die 200 Milliarden die ja
grundsätzlich richtig sind die zur
Senkung der Energiepreise also
Wirtschaft Stabilisierung davon die sind
auch nur kreditfinanziert meine Damen
und Herren das hat mit solider
Haushaltspolitik nicht zu tun ihr
Haushalt ist ein Verschiebebahnhof mit
ungedeckten Sex meine Damen und Herren
und die Bürger die armen im übrigen dass
sie diese Schattenhaushalte bezahlen
müssen und ich will ihnen sagen die
Wirtschaftsweisen haben doch einen
Gegenvorschlag gemacht angesichts der
historischen Krise haben sie gefordert
und zwar völlig zu Recht höhere Steuern
für Topverdiener und Superreiche immer
die Wirtschaftsweisen das sind ihre
eigenen Sachverständigen deren
Sachverstand sie ja offensichtlich
anzweifeln und das obwohl wir in diesem
Jahr mehr Millionäre im Land haben als
je zuvor 1,6 Millionen Vermögens
Millionäre in Deutschland ich meine in
Gutachten der Wirtschaftsweisen heißt es
die Energiekrise solidarisch bewältigen
und das sind zwei zentrale Punkte die
sagen erstens ärmere Haushalte leiden
deutlich mehr unter der Inflation und
zweitens wir brauchen höhere Steuern für
Reiche und mehr Gerechtigkeit um die
Gesellschaft zusammenzuhalten ja wir
brauchen endlich eine Vermögensabgabe
für Milliardäre und Multimillionäre es
geht übrigens nicht darum der
Finanzminister die Steuern zu erhöhen
nein das wollen wir überhaupt nicht wir
wollen sogar Entlastung bei den kleinen
und mittleren Einkommen auch bei
Mittelstand aber sie schützen die
Milliardäre und die Superreichen und das
ist inakzeptabel es kann doch nicht sein
es kann doch nicht sein dass in der
Krise in der Krise die Dax Vorstände
trotz bevorstehender Rezession 25
Prozent mehr Gehalt haben ein
gehaltsfluss von 25 Prozent und hier ist
es eben schon gesagt worden bei der
Tafel gibt es 100% mehr Kundschaft das
ist die Wahrheit und das ist doch nicht
normal meine Damen und Herren da muss
doch politisch gehandelt werden das Land
ist eben nicht gut gerüstet für den
Winter es droht eine verarmungslawine
über Deutschland zu wollen und dann
sagen sie gestern sehr geehrter
Finanzminister wir haben breitflächig
entlastet das waren ihre Worte ehrlich
gesagt was ist denn das für eine
Realitätsverweigerung ja ich weiß es gab
entlastungs-
aber viel zu wenig ist bei den Menschen
angekommen die wirklich die Entlastung
so dringend brauchen meine Damen und
Herren es ist doch so dass viele
Menschen viele Menschen Verständnis
hätten für eine Zeit die wegen des
furchtbaren Kriegs Putins und der Krise
schwieriger ist als zuvor aber viele
Menschen fühlen sich eben nicht
beschützt und unterstützt von ihrer
Regierung die fühlen sich schlicht
ausgeliefert sie haben das Gefühl dass
sie die Folgen von Krieg und Krise
allein tragen müssen dass sie die
Zeitenwende bezahlen müssen und das ist
doch inakzeptabel es reicht nicht
es reicht nicht Blackouts und ein
Zusammenbruch der Gasversorgung zu
verhindern sozial wirtschaftlich und
auch politisch steht dieses Land
vielleicht vor dem schmierigsten Jahr in
der Nachkriegszeit und schauen Sie auf
die Herbstprognose der EU-Kommission
0,3% Wachstum für die gesamte EU und in
Deutschland minus 0,6 ehrlich gesagt in
keinem anderen Land ist die Prognose so
schlecht da muss man doch vielleicht
Schlussfolgerung ziehen mit dem Haushalt
2023 hätten sie einen großen
Schutzschirm über Deutschland spannen
müssen ein Schutzschirm für die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger und für die
Unternehmen gegen Inflation gegen
Insolvenzen und gegenverarmut aber ihr
Haushalt ist kein Schutzschirm kein you
never walk alone ihr Geist spiegelt sich
in diesem Haushalt eben nicht wieder ihr
Haushalt das ist Wellness für die
wohlhabenden und unterlassene
Hilfeleistung für die Mehrheit der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dieses Landes vor
allen Dingen aber ist er zutiefst
unehrlich herzlichen Dank
und das wird der Satz sein der ist dann
heute Abend in die Tagesschau und den
die Tagesthemen ins heute journal und
andere Sendungen schaffte Wellness für
die Wohlhabenden sei der Haushalt 2023
kritisierte dietmarat der Vorsitzende
der Linksfraktion